foreign
let's go to Jose and there's no way this
is the name of his town in Niceville
Florida I love it Jose Niceville is that
for real
yes sir dude I thought you were just
giving us a fake name Niceville
no not at all is it right next to like
never mind never mind that's gonna take
I was gonna take us off the rails uh hey
so what's up man
uh first off thank you for thank you for
your call and thank you for everything
you do on the show it it has helped me
and my family out a lot thank you well
I'm really grateful man thank you so
what's up what are you what are you
working through so my question is how do
I handle anxiety when it comes to flying
so
it for whatever reason recently my I get
super anxious I get nervous I get sweaty
I get all these different emotions when
I start flying and um I don't know has
there been any uh changes in your life
like new kids
um y'all recently bought a house you got
other stuff going on job like jobs kind
of wonky what's going on so so I've been
thinking about this a lot okay so
recently in the last two years
my life has been amazing with my wife
with my kids with my job it's like it's
like everything is flowing in place
and I'm scared on losing it and
I don't
my wife and I had been married uh 14
years and
it hasn't been this good
almost ever
and so so
man I'm smiling
oh dude Jose I feel like I'm talking to
a cooler version of myself
I hate flying and I fly for a living and
I hate it and
ah man I've been in a season of blessing
the last couple years it's not gonna
last forever and I have begun to slowly
hold on to it Tighter and Tighter
to the point that I'm gonna start
constricting it I can already tell start
choking it to death right yeah and when
I start grabbing for control all that
phobia is of the fear of flying
let's be super clear your mortal body is
in a tube a metal tube flying five or
six hundred miles an hour 30 000 feet
above the air
right so that's insane you we I think we
all should be a little bit anxious about
that because that's nuts
um our brains don't have an evolutionary
um
switch for flying in a metal tube 30 000
feet above the air
um and so we should be a little bit
anxious about that but when you have
started to lock in on not losing things
there's just a natural inclination to
begin to hold on to things Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter and then your body
starts scanning the environment for
things it cannot control and it tries to
get your attention
okay and that's all anxiety is it's just
an alarm system and there are fewer
things more out of control than looking
at two dudes that you don't even get to
see they just you hear their voice and
you just trust hope you guys don't kill
us
uh and I would like the snack please and
um seltzer water right that's just it's
it's insanity
and so uh here here's a here's what I'm
gonna just tell you what I do okay okay
the first thing is my body starts
getting anxious I about flying and it's
kind of a ramp up for me I start packing
I put off packing until the very last
second and then I create a whirling
dervish of chaos and I start throwing
crap in I always forget something and
then I get mad I forgot it
um and then I race to the airport
driving too fast because I've now
created a situation where I'm gonna be
late and I'm already amped up
and then I started getting nervous and
all the things I literally will
consciously take a deep breath and
exhale and drop my shoulders down
and I will force a giant smile onto my
face
and I will say to myself sometimes out
loud like like a person who is no longer
well or sane
I know you're just trying to take care
of me because I'm getting ready to go
flying at 30 000 feet in the air
I'm good I'm going on this flight
and I head in that way and I literally
will feel that and I'll let it run
through me and generally speaking by the
time I make it all the way to the gate
and I sit down in kind of a
I'm usually pretty good A couple other
things that help me is gum I chew I'll
go through a whole pack of sugar-free
gum not a pack of like six but like a
box of gum
okay I also have headphones and I've
downloaded you can get on the podcast
and download like I don't know it sounds
like a yoga music or like massage music
or something binaural beats is something
I love and I will just listen to those
and I just I basically here's what I'm
accepting
that I have put my hands my life in the
hands of two men or women that I'll
probably never make eye contact with and
that I'm probably not going to die and
if I do there's nothing I can do about
it because I've already decided I'm
Gonna Fly
you see what I'm saying at that point
it's too late it's too late the ship has
sailed like yeah it's like trying I
don't want to fight I don't want to
fight well you're a boxer and they just
ding the Bell so you're in a fight now
now the only question is how badly are
you gonna get beat up or you can
actually try to fight back so when it
comes to this I feel it I smile about it
I don't go to war with my body most of
the angst with anxiety is fighting the
anxiety itself or getting anxious about
getting anxious have you gotten there
yet
yeah so for me it happens like a day
before yeah so the day before like I'll
pack I'll get ready then like I'll take
the kids out we'll go to the beach we'll
go get dinner we'll go do something and
I one of the things in my mind is like
man well but if this is the last time I
see my kids or the last time I see my
wife and that whole first day is running
to my mind until I get to the airport
even when I get to the airport it's like
all right don't die but like how you're
saying I have no control yeah so I
actually think the the question what if
this is the last day I could see my kids
is a question we should all ask way way
way more often
because the majority of us run through
our lives as though our current
situation is never going to end both
good and bad
those of us in a season of blessing just
assume we're always going to make this
much money and the life our lights are
always going to be on and there's always
going to be this and the car is always
going to start and the tires are never
going to be flat and then we all have a
rude awakening coming for us and those
that think I'm always going to be
depressed I'm always going to be anxious
I'm always going to be just a trauma
Survivor they'd have a hard time seeing
this that the sun comes up to
and so I would tell you that don't run
from that
actually sit for a minute and I would
actually do it more often than just that
one day what if it's the last day I see
my kids one of the things that I did
regularly I need to get back into it in
2023 is I would write my kids a quick
letter
I just want you to know that I love you
I just want you to know that I'm so
proud I'm so grateful that I get to be
your dad and my subversive motive for
that was what if this is the last time I
get to see him
I want that that when their dad dies in
a plane crash which by the way
statistically speaking is never gonna
happen it's never gonna happen you and I
statistically speaking of way more
likelihood that we're going to die in
our cars frantically driving to the
airport that we are in a car and a plane
ride crash but I wanted them to have
that letter and for some reason writing
that letter to them before I left town
was good leaving a letter on my wife's
pillow
um if she was gone already or um right
by where the coffee maker is in the
morning when I knew she was going to go
first thing in the morning man that gave
me peace because I get to say the last
the last words does that make sense
no it does and it makes a lot of sense I
I don't have any problem with you
thinking what if this is the last moment
I think this is I think that helps us
make our time a little more precious
that's an old stoic philosophy
um Memento more I like remember we're
gonna die
when that it's when that becomes
paralyzing and I can't get on a plane
and then I can't leave the house and I
can't you know I mean that's when it
gets too far that's when our bodies spin
out on us that's why I think showing
actually get in the car going to the
airport and smiling dropping your
shoulders and saying
ah
this is it
I'm not gonna die and if I do nothing I
can do about it because I'm getting on
this plane and by the way real quick
Jose I want to back out for just one
second
um
things are really good and you've worked
really good to create a non-anxious life
and you're in a season of blessing
and so things like an emergency fund
for if you lose your job or something
breaks on the house
let me say it this way if worrying or
anxiousness is your drug
seasons of Peace will feel like hell
they will feel
um like you're not prepared you're not
ready it's that dream that you wake up
and you're supposed to be giving a
presentation at school and you haven't
studied or you're the guitarist of a
band and you're suddenly on stage you
know how to play the song
and that that dream comes to life for
those of us who have lived lives of
worry and anxiousness for whatever
reason seasons of Peace feel very
foreboding
um I think it's brene brown that says we
start rehearsing tragedy
we start practicing for when it all goes
down
and man I just decided to quit living
like that I have prepared my life as
much as possible for if and when things
can happen I don't have a plan for if
the monetary system collapses and we're
trading coffee and bullets for food I
don't have a plan for that
um my plan is to go find a prepper and
do never mind so I
I've planned appropriately and now I've
been in a season the last four or five
years of practicing being at peace it's
practicing
practicing living non-anxiously and it's
been incredible
because my body's adjusted
and it can Gear Up what it needs to but
most of the time it lives in a state of
so good so Jose I want you I want to
challenge you brother
intentionally open your hands
to your incredible marriage to your
incredible relationship with your kids
to your good situation at home and at
work
hold those things Loosely because
they're going to cut they're not they're
not gonna come and go your family's not
going to come and go but
there's gonna be seasons of good times
and seasons of tough times and if you
hang on to the the good times so hard
you'll end up suffocating them while
they're still good times
hold on to them Loosely build yourself a
non-anxious life
and then learn practice
on dealing with whatever comes
because it's going to come anyway right
I might as well not go to war
prematurely I might as well enjoy the
peace when there's peace and enjoy the
good times when they're good and be
prepared for when times get tough and
worrying and being anxious about them
never helped with any of those things
I'm grateful grateful for you brother
and congratulations on building a
non-anxious life